[Music]
hello álex salud andrés gonzález these
are the most outstanding headlines of the
day more hospitals will distribute
the coronavirus vaccine
today the doses arrived on monday at
johns y hospital and are expected to
reach VA medical centers and the
hospital  sant rights, which has already been
preparing for the arrival
of the vaccine for several days, just yesterday sunrise carried out
a drill for when they receive the
shipment at their facilities and thus ensure
that everything goes perfectly well, the
churches in nevada will now be able to
receive more of their parishioners in  their temples
yesterday a federal judge of an
appeals court decided that churches
will be able to have up to 25 percent of
their capacity instead of limiting them to 50
people as they had been ordered in
the security restrictions in the face of the
pandemic several churches and united  and they
sued the state of nevada alleging
that the restrictions that churches were asked to do
were much stricter.  ictas
that other businesses such
as hotels and casinos
and the hotel company wynn resorts said
that it is opening forced to cut
jobs next month the wynn hotel
to avoid cuts said that it has already reduced
hours to its sector of employees but the
union  Culinary is demanding that
its employees work 40 hours per
week the hotel responded to the
union and said that this request
was not possible and that it will have to cut
jobs and make temporary layoffs
from January 11
and the raiders are being impacted
by the coronavirus  and they announced that one
of their team members will be absent
from tomorrow's game due to the
coronavirus the player general rocks
a roster appeared the
nfl coronavirus and several players from the radios
have missed practices and games
during this pandemic
let's see what the temperatures have in store for us
For today and the rest of the
week in the extended forecast today
we will have a sunny day with  n a maximum
of 59 degrees and a minimum of 42 for
tomorrow the winds return and with
temperatures in the high 50s for
Friday and Saturday this in the information
for today informed you by andrés
gonzález and this one about the
news now  in Spanish
[Music]